A set is an unordered
collection of distinct values.
Like arrays and dictionaries, sets can
be initialized with literal syntax or
initializer syntax.
Notice that if I add two identical
values to my set, the compiler
doesn't complain, but it doesn't add
that repeated item either because,
of course, sets have no repeats.
You'll find that inserting,
removing, and
counting items from sets is similar to
working with arrays and dictionaries.
Here I'm adding all of the emoji
trees to the trees set.
Oops, except a cactus isn't really
a tree, so let's remove that one.
And remember you can get to the emoji
keyboard by pressing Ctrl/Cmd+Spacebar.
So we can remove the cactus
using the remove method.
And as always if you want to know
how many items are in the set,
you can use the count method which
is available to all collections.
And that should be enough to
get you started with sets.
You'll find they aren't used as
frequently as arrays and dictionaries.
But for more on operations for
defining, manipulating, and
comparing sets, follow the link
in the instructor's notes.